[Music]
I'm Arena faruko I'm one of the product
leaders for our smart analytics
portfolio and joining me today is Steve
Jared SVP of data and AI at Orange Steve
has been a product and Technology
innovator across many stored Silicon
Valley companies like digital magic
Apple Facebook as well as a CEO of and
founder CEO of a technology startup and
I'm really excited for Steve to share
the journey that his team is on trying
to transform orange with data and AI on
a global
scale but before we delve into the
deeper detail as you saw this morning in
the keynote generative AI represents a
generational opportunity to to rethink
how we interact with the world whether
it's new customer experiences whether
it's um employee productivity on new
category defining products that none of
us thought were even possible a few
months ago just like many of us can't
even imagine a world without the
internet I guess is that a very short
period of time we will not remember what
the world was like without generative
AI every Enterprise in the world is
thinking and putting plans on how do
they leverage generative AI for their
data many are already way on the way
towards that Journey but for many others
it remains a tremendous challenge
because they are not they don't have the
right data
Foundation instead their data is
distributed and silos where every single
Innovation project becomes a complex
data engineering project moving data
around duplicating data and trying to
connect different systems with different
metadata and Technologies together to
make the data available to their users
in their tools of
choice Google has reinvented the way
customers use data and information and
our Google cloud data and AI cloud is
trying to do the same for your data and
your
AI with the same Simplicity security
intelligence and scale that you're used
to across our other
products it starts with getting you on
the right data
Foundation unifying all your data
irrespective of where it is giv you the
flexibility to use the best tools in the
ecosystem and infusing AI for all
personas for the end to-end workflows
and
simplification so has anybody here heard
of a lake
house I'm just
kidding lake house is a foundational
industry term to describe the
convergence between data Leakes and data
warehouses
that convergence is foundational for the
Next Generation Innovation around data
and
AI it's less about the underlying
technology it's more around the
productivity gains and Innovation that
you can achieve by getting onto that
unified
architecture here at Google Cloud we
strive to give you the best platform to
build your AI Lakehouse that has four
key components
one unifying all your data structured
unstructured badge streaming here on
Google cloud or beyond the boundaries in
a cross Cloud
fashion given you the openness and
flexibility to store your data in any
open format and use the best of Google
tools as well as from the open-source
ecosystem to help you
innovate as you build your platform
governance and especially data to AI
governance plays a critical role to make
sure that you can inovate in a fast
secure and responsible
fashion and last but definitely not the
least is activating your data with AI
whether it's making your data seamlessly
access accessible to your gen
applications on making your us end users
more productive with duet Ai and AI
activation
there this platform is allowing
customers like dun and Brad street to
unify data lakes and data warehouses and
bring rapidly new generation of
self-service datadriven capabilities
while improving their performance the
performance of their analytics by
5X let's take a look at some of the
exciting new things we're announcing
here at
next one of the first foundational
components of our lake house
architecture is Big Lake a unified
storage layer for all of your structured
and unstructured
data today we're announcing General
availability of support for Iceberg
hoodie and Delta in Big Lake with fine
grain security and performance
acceleration we are also announcing
managed tables for a Pache Iceberg
giving you high throughput streaming
ingestion storage
optimizations and DML all while
maintaining full Iceberg Rita
compatibility as you can see big lake is
pretty unique in the industry in the
fact that it gives you full flexibility
in storing your data in the right
formats open formats that you choose by
giving you security and performance at
Google
scale what we've done here is we've
taken the learnings from running Planet
scale systems with big qu and brought
those learnings around security
governance data management two open
formats so we remove the unglamorous
tasks of data management M and
engineering and let you focus simply on
using your
data another capability that I'm
particularly excited about is the
general availability of object tables
for all of your unstructured data like
images files
audio now you can seamlessly combine in
your analysis structured and
unstructured data prepare your training
Co Corpus for AI
applications and seamlessly integrate
with document AI for an endtoend data
toai
workflow many of our customers are
already seeing Big Lake as
transformational to their
applications take for example Deutsche
Bank who seen Big Lake as
transformational for their risk system
one of the largest in the world and
really is one of the core technologies
that will Define the impact that cloud
could have on um on their
applications the other set of
capabilities we're announcing around
streamlining your data to AI
workflow today we're making available
llms and specifically vertex
foundational models directly from
bigquery while col an llm from mqu may
not be as big of a deal but doing that
in a full secure scalable and compliant
fashion where your data remains within
the boundaries of your security
perimeter is really
important we also announcing the ga of
bqu inference engine so now you can run
large scale inference of our Google
pre-train models or any of your own
models in tensor flow Onyx or XG boost
formats all with familiar tools like
SQL embeddings moving on to embeddings
one of the most powerful Concepts in
machine learning we are now bringing
that capability to bigquery in scalable
and secure
fashion now you can build nextg
applications like semantic search and
recommendation systems as well as
seamlessly and at scale do llm
fine-tuning and last but definitely not
the least in this set of capabilities is
the big query data frames for all the
python developers out there giving you a
python API that's psychic learn and uh
Panda compatible add big query scale
right parab scale all all from the same
environment as you unified your data and
you streamline your data to AI workflow
we're also helping your users
collaborate more seamlessly in bigquery
studio a unified workspace for your data
Engineers data analysts data scientists
to collaborate using their language of
choice or framework of choice whether
it's SQL python JavaScript or even
natural language all integrated with
your SQL pipelines and um
um uh sorry and uh data quality and
lineage all embedded to help give you
the trust and the intelligence about
your
data and lastly as you saw on the
keynote stage we're bringing duet AI to
all all the data analytics products big
query and looker and datax and others
coming soon across spark beam and airf
flow what this allows you to do is
really making your users much more
productive in the context of their
existing workflows let's take for
example in bigquery now I get powerful
capabilities around SQL generation autoc
completion as well as I cited assistant
to help me understand the capabilities
and help educate me on the best way to
use the
system as you leverage all this
intelligence across your data Suite one
of the most foundational things that you
can do is make sure you're operating on
the right data to AI governance
foundation so your users can innovate
with the right data in their tools of
choice without compromising on your
policies and your governance guard
LS with data Plex we have been leading
the market around centralized management
and governance and in fact over 70% of
to analytics customers I using data Flex
to simplify the management and
governance of their integrated
platform it provides unified metadata
across your distributed data centralized
security and policy management M and
data intelligence with automatic life
cycle management data lineage and data
quality and today we're excited to
announce that we extending data Plex to
vertex AI models and data sets so now
you have a single integrated always on
catalog that has all of the metadata
around your entire platform from data to
AI that really serves as a foundation
for Providence for governance and for
streamlined workflows for all of your
users across their
tools but governance doesn't stop at the
boundaries of Google cloud and we've
integrated datax with bigquery Omni and
big lake for multicloud governance where
in areas where you have bigquery uh Omni
you will now get a centralized
catalog a centralized ability to apply
policies an endtoend lineage as your
data moves across its life
cycle we're also excited to announce the
general availability of data plx data
quality and
profiling we've brought a lot of
intelligence in automation to really
solve the age-old problem when you're
sitting around the table conference
table and somebody says I don't trust
that data point and the whole meeting
goes off the
rails it's one thing when there there
it's a bunch of humans sitting in the
meeting and in other ways it's when
machines have to make decisions and
making sure that you can automate and
they're operating on the high quality
data with data Flex data profiling in
quality we will automatically profile
your data we automatically generate
recommended rules and we execute them
and surface them to the users in their
tools of choice so let's say that I'm a
user a data engineer working in bigquery
studio trying to perform some analysis
of build a pipeline in context I can see
the quality of that data the information
about that data and helps me gain trust
and intelligence about that
data another capab ability that we're
announcing today is the extension of our
data lineage
capabilities lineage Providence is
critically important to build trust in
your data but use it as a foundation for
compliance and perform impact and roota
root cause
analysis we've had for a while the
capabilities for lineage and biter as
well as our pipelining tools like
composer and now we're extending lineage
to Apache Spark
so you can see endtoend lineage
capabilities across your entire data
life cycle but we also know that your
ecosystem doesn't stop with Google Cloud
products and so today we're announcing
the support for open lineage apis where
you can integrate dataplex lineage with
any open source system or any system
that supports open lineage and see it
within the same intelligent graph in
your current and existing
workflows but all of these capabilities
are just beginning in the
foundation how do you then solve what
we're focused on and especially with d
AI is how do you solve the ageold cold
start problem how do I even know which
data I should be looking for or what
questions I can ask of my
data this is why I'm excited to announce
the AI capabilities in datax where we
will automatically surface the questions
you can ask your data based on our
understanding of the metadata that you
have as well as usage patterns for
popular queries that you have uh that
other users are using within your
environment then we will use it as a
continuous feedback loop for your users
to provide feedback on how useful this
was to them as a starting point and then
start their analysis and use that as a
jump off point there we're really hoping
that many of you will provide us
feedback on that capability to help
Drive the next level of innovation for
metadata powered insights and
democratizing your
data I've talked a lot about the cool
new capabilities around our na products
bit query datax uh you heard about
Vortex aai but we also have a
longstanding commitment to open source
and from the analytics side that has
been a tremendous commitment
specifically to aachi
spark we are committed to for Google
Cloud being the best place to run open-
Source spark with the industry leading
price
performance over the past year we've
innovated tremendously to improve the
price performance of Open Source park
with many customers seeing 50 to 70%
Improvement within their existing
environments we've also innovated on the
customer experience serverless spark
gives you a true serverless experience
for aache spark across all
workloads today data engineers and
developers spend over only 40% of their
time writing code and instead 60% of the
time managing infrastructure and all of
the glue that comes around it we've
dramatically simplified that with
servess
spark and today I'm excited to announce
that we're extending servess spk for
data science with servus spark sessions
we're providing coste effective and
rapid development for data science
workloads across vertex
AI across your own Jupiter notebooks and
as well as partner Integrations that are
coming soon with hex and deep
note as you heard in the keynote stage
earlier this morning we're also deleting
Servo spark service to integrate with
Nvidia for both performance acceleration
and cost
savings everything we've talked about
today has been focused on analytics in
the
cloud but we also know there's a set of
Leading Edge use cases that span The
Edge and the cloud right those could be
in retail manufacturing Financial
Services where the amount of data you're
processing in the edge sometimes is so
large that you you have to make a
decision before you can make a round
trip to the cloud or there are cases
where you have data sovereignty
requirements where you are not able to
send all of the data before you
pre-process and anonymize
it this is where Google distributed
Cloud comes in Google think of Google
distributed Cloud as a true extension of
Google cloud in your own data center
with a single unified control plane and
management plane letting you run
distributed applications across data and
AI that makes sense for your
business and today I'm incredibly
excited to announce that we've extended
our spark offering to Google distributed
Cloud you can now run a fully manage
Apache spark on Google distributed Cloud
you can pre animize on anonymize data
aggregate data or truly run distributed
workloads across data and Ai and that
environment and with this I am delighted
to welcome Steve to the stage to sh
who's been a key launch partner for a
lot of these capabilities to share the
journey they've been on at Orange thank
you Steve thanks Serena and thanks so
much for the great partnership between
our engineering
teams orange is one of the world's
leading Telecom providers we offer
services in 26 countries that you see
here on the map ranging from our host
country France to countries like Egypt
and Morocco and and the Democratic
Republic of Congo and so the breadth of
our challenges is really extreme and
I'll talk more about how we're working
with Google to solve some of those as a
company we're known for a lot of our
Cutting Edge contributions to Telco in
fact a lot of the power saving modes
that are in 5G are there because Orange
has cared about those kinds of issues
for many many years and we're
contributing to Future versions of these
fundamental Technologies like
6G but we also have a longstanding
fundamental commitment to Pure research
in fact in my own team we have 50 people
that are in the pure research team
working on data in AI
topics the way that we like to describe
AI at Orange is that it gives us super
powers to our employees to our networks
and to our customer interactions and we
have already many high impact use cases
in those domains mostly where the
business has a lot of capex and Opex
today where we see data and being able
to bring a lot of efficiencies and
improvements in those domains so for
example in Reinventing the customer
experience we use AI today to
dramatically improve the the offers that
we're providing to people the the the
interest of those offers we're also
working to improve our call centers by
using generative AI to live transcribe
the call with the consumer and you can
imagine across our 26 countries how many
different languages were're were we
faced with on a daily
basis and the idea that we can live
transcribe that call with AI and then
use the AI to prompt the call center
agent with suggestions of what to how to
resolve the customer's problem we can
then use AI to summarize that call for
for storage but also we can autogenerate
a follow-up email that could be very
useful you know helps the customer agent
save time to create that email that can
cover the topics that they covered in
the call as well as suggested items for
them to solve their problem long
term in operating efficiency we're using
AI uh large language models as an
interface to a lot of the really complex
data we have today in the company and in
fact we we find that pairing a large
language model with a knowledge base is
very very powerful and then lastly in
terms of our
networks across all 26 countries we're
generating over a petabyte a day of just
the Telemetry data that's coming off of
the equipment so being able to to work
with that data is is a really
significant problem but the idea that we
use AI to do not only predictive Network
maintenance but also longterm to
identify the root cause of the problem
so you can imagine how many cell sites
we have in the field so if we can use AI
to determine an advance of the truck
rolling to the cell site to identify
what the problem is that can help send
the right technician with the right
equipment and also save a lot of
time so we've been on this
journey of trying to improve the way
that we work with data ni across all of
our businesses and we started with these
very diverse requirements and in fact
inside of each country what we had is
many times the operating business unit
would create their own data stack and so
we would have a silo a data Silo from
the marketing team or the finance team
and the networks team that reflected
those organizational silos and so the
complexity was extremely high and each
of those ecosystems had their own
process data model and so on and so the
result was that as Arena was saying the
teams were spending all of their time
just managing the data infrastructure as
opposed to focused on on generating
value for the
business then we attempted to build and
integrate our own infrastructure that
was very kubernetes Centric and we found
that it's not just another it workload
there's lots of complexity around
identity and access management
compliance security and and and and so
we learned very quickly that we needed
to have a really strong partner and so
we chose
Google we also found that because of the
dynamic uh how fast the AI
infrastructure business was moving the
fact that we were working with fairly
monolithic vendors was also a big
problem so we needed to have a partner
that was ow us to to use much more open
Technologies and move much
faster so in terms of our ambition we
we're we're working towards this much
more modular plug-and-play architecture
and the idea that we can leverage both
open source am AI
models open data Technologies but also
manage services like the spark uh
offering that Arena mentioned is very
powerful for us and the fact that we can
run this now on GDC Edge gives us an
infrastructure on premise where we can
manage the data in a way that saves us a
lot of cost because the data that we're
generating is so large that we need a
really sophisticated way to filter that
data before we would send it to public
cloud and the fact that with GDC Edge
this infrastructure is
uniform and so we can have uniform
measure management of these systems
between what we have for gcp in the
public cloud and what we would have on
Prem is very
powerful and also the fact that these
regulatory requirements we have from
country to Country they change over time
and so again having a fairly flexible
infrastructure to respond to those is
extremely useful for
us so to give you a Peak at what this
architecture looks like on the left hand
side you have all of our on premise
systems that relate to these different
business units and their data
sources and then in the middle we have
the bridge of GDC Edge between our on
premise systems and and and the pub
cloud and there you see our ability to
run not only things like uh like the
spark manage instance we can also run AI
models there we can do inference of AI
models there and manage it with airf
flow the data comes from our onpress
Prem systems into Google cloud and there
in a very secure Zone that's where we
offer and build data products and then
the data is consumed by the different
business units in the sharing layer and
when they generate data that they think
is useful to be shared with other teams
it's written back to the secure
Zone and at the bottom you see the data
Operation Center so we work with calbra
to provide business metadata across all
of our systems not just the ones that
are residing on Google and also a
Marketplace and for us this vision is
really fundamental to our strategy the
idea that we have a marketplace where
you can discover data and consume data
is really really um it's we have to
dramatically open up the access to data
across the business and the fact we have
these data protection um dashboards and
alerts that are provided by dataplex
including much improved data
observation and this Federated
governance that can help us manage the
data whether it's on Prem or whe whether
it's in in Google
Cloud so we're on this journey towards
this vision of a data democracy and for
us a data democracy is not an anarchy of
data it's a system where we have rules
by which are that are enforced using
policy as
code and within that
environment the user has a lot of
freedom to get the job done with data so
the first point is this idea that I
mentioned before about breaking down
these silos that we had that map the
organizational silos so now we can have
availability of data across these
different business teams and
units the second as I mentioned was this
elegant management between what's on PR
and what's on public Cloud our existing
infrastructure that we inherited in many
of these countries the architecture is
very very inflexible especially between
these business units so having this be
really elegant between on Prem and
public cloud and having uniform
management infrastructure is really
powerful and this D this dynamism allows
us to respond to things that are
unexpected so for example let's say
we're training a new AI model and we
don't know what data is predictive and
so the idea that we can send a we can
send for a relatively short period of
time a large amount of that data to
public Cloud for model
training then we can deploy the models
back down uh in country to be run on
inference on this GDC Edge
infrastructure is really really
useful but also let's say we encounter
an unexpected event in the network where
we have a a failure in the network and
again you know given that we're
generating across the company over a
petabyte of a day of just the Telemetry
data in a country where we have a
problem we can send a vast amount of
that data to public Cloud for training
when normally a lot of that data would
be aggregated or or even deleted over
time and the only way to do this really
at massive
scale is to use policy as code and so
the way that the fact that we can use
this this at a role based approach uh
where we can ensure that users who have
access to certain data are are doing the
right thing and also that we have the
ability to observe their operations
really helps with compliance and also
dramatically reduces our security and
privacy
risks one of the things that I don't
think has been mentioned yet at the show
about GDC Edge that's interesting is
that one of our concerns from a lot of
our Regulators was uh what data was
passing between the public cloud and the
suppliance on premise and so Google
provided us with an open-source proxy
called The Boundary proxy that we can
run on Prem and inspect everything
that's running over the management plane
and so if we see something unexpected we
can sever the connection between the
appliance and the and Google cloud and
because the the control plane of GDC
Edge is running locally the appliance
can continue to operate and it can
operate for as long as we need to to
then correct the problem uh and then
reestablish the
connection so the fact that we can have
this uniform architecture the fact that
we can have this environment to run AI
model inference but also have our own
first-party or open- Source data
Technologies we can Leverage The manage
services from Google and we expect to
see more and more of those over time and
in fact we also believe that this will
become a really thriving ecosystem where
we'll have many more services coming
from people like you and the audience
that we can pick and choose from and so
the idea that our on premise data and AI
infrastructure becomes this really
flexible relatively easy to manage uh
environment is really a breakthrough for
us in terms of Elegance and simplicity
and it also dramatically reduces the
complexity of the training that we need
to provide to our
teams uh you know one of our challenges
is that we have very very good data
engineering resources in all of these
countries but with Antiquated
architectures they were spending all of
their time just keeping the lights on on
the infrastructure as opposed to adding
value and lastly the fact that we can
use this architecture to really rapidly
respond to changing requirements that
are that come from our Regulators across
all of our countries uh was really
fundamental to us so Arena thanks again
for helping us towards this our journey
towards a data democracy and also to
give superpowers to everybody at Orange
and uh what do you want to do next well
than Steve and thank you for the
partnership I'll go with a few
unscripted questions maybe okay
um you know it's so impressive with what
you and your team have been able to
accomplish in such a short period of
time and we all know these
Transformations are like I would want to
take credit for all the products I built
but I know a lot is about people and
processes sure internally and having
such a large distributed organization
and driving change at this rapid Pace
I'd love I think all of us probably in
the audience would love to hear what
have been the true keys to drive that
change armit technology that we have
here that's a great question so we did a
few things the first is we chose a
training partner we chose corsera we use
their tools widely across the whole
company and we make those available to
everybody on an unlimited basis that was
really fundamental the second was we're
very very transparent in the way that we
work with one another so all of the work
that we do so for example all of the
cloud foundation work we did with for
gcp we share all of that work and we're
very transparent about our metrics so
for each of the projects that I
mentioned we have really clear kpis that
we've defined across the companies and
we share our successes and failures
openly on a very regular basis so that
allows the teams that know that one team
for example poer in the front row from
Poland they've done a particularly good
job in a number of domains and the fact
that we're so transparent about that
allows the different leaders across all
26 countries to reach out for for help
um so I think it's really a balance of
being
measurable uh and transparent at the
same time and that's enabled us to move
a lot faster than we were in the
past